Hey there, everybody. So I'm not going to beat around the bush. For this week's radio program, we think we may have found the original recipe for Coca-Cola. And I am not kidding. I am not kidding. One of the most famously guarded trade secrets on the planet, I have it right here, and I'm going to read it to you. I'm going to read it to the world. And I'm going to make my case for why I think it's real, despite whatever Coca-Cola might say. And that is just one of the two stories on today's program.
大家好。我就不兜圈子了。对于本周的广播节目，我们认为我们可能找到了可口可乐的原始配方。我可没在开玩笑。我真的没在开玩笑。这是这个星球上最著名的商业机密之一，我把它拿在手里，我打算读给你们听。我打算读给全世界听。而且我要陈述我的理由，说明为什么我认为它是真实的，不管可口可乐公司怎么说。这只是今天节目中两个故事中的一个。
From WBEZ Chicago, it is This American Life , distributed by Public Radio International. I'm Ira Glass.
来自芝加哥WBEZ，这是《美国生活》，由公共广播国际公司发行。我是艾拉·格拉斯。
Probably the best story about how protective Coca-Cola is of its secret formula comes from this book that was written by Charles Howard Candler. His Dad, Asa, did not invent Coca-Cola, but founded the Coca-Cola company back in 1892.
关于可口可乐对其秘密配方保护得有多严密，最好的故事可能来自查尔斯·霍华德·坎德勒写的那本书。他的父亲阿萨（Asa）并没有发明可口可乐，但他在1892年创立了可口可乐公司。
And Charles, the son, wrote this. "One of the proudest moments of my life came when my father initiated me into the mysteries of the secret flavoring formula, inducting me into the holy of holies." Charles then says, "Incredibly there was no written formula and the labels had been removed from all the containers of the ingredients." So they were, quote, "identified only by sight, smell, and remembering where each was put on the shelf. And I thereupon experienced the thrill of making up, with his guidance, a batch of merchandise 7x." Merchandise 7x. Merchandise 7x is the cartoonishly super secret, cloak and dagger name they give the flavoring mixture in Coca-Cola.
作为儿子的查尔斯写道：“我一生中最自豪的时刻之一，是父亲向我传授秘密调味配方的奥秘，将我引入了神圣的殿堂。”查尔斯随后说：“令人难以置信的是，根本没有书面配方，所有成分容器上的标签都被去掉了。”所以，用他的话来说，“只能通过看、闻，并记住每种成分放在架子的什么位置来识别。随后，在他的指导下，我体验到了配制一批‘商品7x’的快感。”商品7x。商品7x是他们给可口可乐中那种调味混合物起的一个卡通化、超级神秘、秘密特工般的名字。
Charles' dad, Asa, was so paranoid about anybody else getting hold of the secret formula for 7x that, even though he was president of Coca-Cola-- he's president of the company-- he would go through the company mail himself and remove the invoices for any ingredients that had been purchased, so that nobody in the accounting department could read what ingredients had been bought for the product. I learned all this from a history of Coca-Cola, a book written by investigative journalist and historian Mark Pendergrast.
查尔斯的父亲阿萨对任何其他人获取7x秘密配方都非常多疑，以至于即使他身兼可口可乐公司总裁——他是公司的总裁——他也会亲自检查公司邮件，并取走所有已购原料的发票，这样会计部门就没人能看到该产品购买了什么成分。这一切都是我从可口可乐的历史中了解到的，这是一本由调查记者兼历史学家马克·彭德格拉斯特撰写的书。
The company has always said, and as far as I know it's true, that only two people at any given time know how to actually mix the 7x flavoring ingredient. And that these people never travel on the same airplane in case it crashes. It's this carefully passed on secret ritual. And that the formula is kept in a bank vault at Sun Trust, which used to be the Georgia Trust Company.
公司一直声称，据我所知这也是事实，在任何时候都只有两个人知道如何真正混合7x调味成分。而且这些人从不乘坐同一架飞机，以防坠机。这是一个被小心传承的秘密仪式。而且该配方保存在太阳信托银行（Sun Trust）的保险库中，该银行以前叫乔治亚信托公司。
Of course this makes no sense at all. Why can't the two guys fly on a plane if the formula is sitting inside a bank vault? Coke's official line on this these days is that they simply do not talk about how many people know the recipe. Though the reason that most of us think that of it as one of the biggest trade secrets in the world is probably because that's the story Coca-Cola likes to tell.
当然，这根本说不通。如果配方就在银行金库里，那两个人为什么不能坐同一架飞机呢？可口可乐公司现在的官方说法是，他们根本不讨论有多少人知道配方。不过我们大多数人之所以认为它是世界上最严密的商业机密之一，可能是因为这就是可口可乐喜欢讲述的故事。
Coke's secret formula. Only two guys in the world know it. If something happened to one, the formula would be lost forever. And then, cookouts would be catastrophic.
可口可乐的秘密配方。世界上只有两个人知道。如果其中一个人出了什么事，配方就会永远失传。然后，烧烤野餐就会变成一场灾难。
In this particular Coke commercial, I guess the premise is that each of the two guys only knows half the formula. It's just one of several commercials that have come out recently that poke fun at the myth of the super secret formula, while at the same time bolstering and selling that myth.
在这个特定的可乐广告中，我想其前提是这两个人每个人只知道配方的一半。这只是最近出现的几个拿超级秘密配方的神话开玩笑的广告之一，同时它们也在强化和兜售这种神话。
Coke even has this thrill ride at its museum in Atlanta, The World of Coca-Cola, where you follow two characters who are trying to unlock the secret formula for Coca-Cola. So with all this money, all this energy, all these millions of dollars spent over the years to convince us of just how impossibly, importantly, iconically secret the formula to Coca-Cola is, it was, a surprise when we stumbled across an article in Coke's hometown paper, the Atlanta Journal and Constitution , February 18, 1979. Not on the front page, but buried. Buried back on page 2B. One of their columnists, Charles Saulter, without any fanfare at all, published what looks like the original recipe for Coca-Cola.
可乐甚至在亚特兰大的博物馆“可口可乐世界”里有一个惊险游乐设施，在那里你可以跟随两个试图解开可口可乐秘密配方的角色。因此，经过多年的投入、精力和数百万美元的宣传，让我们相信可口可乐的配方是多么不可思议、多么重要、多么具有标志性的机密，当我们偶然在可乐家乡的报纸《亚特兰大宪法报》1979年2月18日的一篇文章中看到这个配方时，着实感到惊讶。不是在头版，而是被埋没在内页。埋在2B版。他们的专栏作家查尔斯·索尔特（Charles Saulter）没有任何铺垫，就公布了看起来是可口可乐原始配方的内容。
He found it in a pharmacist's old book of recipes. All the recipes, including the one for Coca-Cola, are written by hand. Most of them are for various ointments and remedies.
他在一本药剂师的老配方书中发现了它。所有的配方，包括可口可乐的配方，都是手写的。大多数是各种药膏和疗法。
And if that seems like a strange and random place to find this kind of thing, well, Coca-Cola was invented by a pharmacist, and it was originally sold at pharmacy soda fountains. The article says that the book passed from one pharmacist to another until it fell into the hands of one Everett Beal, who owned a drug store in Griffin, Georgia, 40 miles from Atlanta. He is mainly identified in the story as a fishing buddy of the columnist.
如果觉得在这种奇怪和随机的地方发现这种东西很奇怪，好吧，可口可乐是由一位药剂师发明的，最初是在药房的汽水柜台上出售。文章说，这本书从一位药剂师传给另一位，直到落入埃弗里特·比尔（Everett Beal）手中，他在距离亚特兰大40英里的乔治亚州格里芬市拥有一家药店。在故事中，他主要被描述为专栏作家的钓鱼伙伴。
Hello?
喂？
Judy?
朱迪？
Yes, you're late.
嗯，你迟到了。
I know I am.
我知道。
Did you have a nice flight back home?
回家的航班还顺利吗？
Everett Beal passed away July 2010. I called his widow Judy at her home in Georgia so many times asking for an interview that at one point she said to me, "This is how you people won the war, isn't it?" "You people" meaning northerners.
埃弗里特·比尔于2010年7月去世。我多次打电话给他在乔治亚州的遗孀朱迪要求采访，有一次她对我说：“你们这些人就是靠这个赢得战争的，对吧？”“你们这些人”指的是北方佬。
And you wanted to know how Everett got this book?
你想知道埃弗里特是怎么得到这本书的吗？
Yes.
是的。
Well RR Evans was a good friend of Pemberton's.
嗯，RR·埃文斯是彭伯顿的好朋友。
OK, let's just pause the tape right there to explain who these guys are. The Pemberton that she's talking about is John Pemberton, the guy who invented Coca-Cola in Atlanta back in 1886. Like I said, he was a pharmacist. But he was also a maker of patent medicines. He made something called Globe Flower Cough Syrup. He made a blood purifier called Extract of [? Stalengia. ?]
好了，让我们暂停录音来解释一下这些人是谁。她提到的彭伯顿是约翰·彭伯顿（John Pemberton），就是1886年在亚特兰大发明可口可乐的那个人。正如我所说，他是一位药剂师。但他也是专利药的制造商。他制造了一种叫“地球花止咳糖浆”的东西。他制造了一种叫“[? Stalengia ?]提取物”的血液净化剂。
RR Evans-- that's the second person that she mentioned-- Judy says, was another pharmacist in Atlanta at the time.
RR·埃文斯——那是她提到的第二个人——朱迪说，是当时亚特兰大的另一位药剂师。
And they were best friends and blah, blah, blah.
他们是最好的朋友，诸如此类。
This book of recipes, Judy says, originally belonged to Evans. She says his name is all over the book. Apparently after his friend Pemberton invented Coke, Evans copied down the formula in this book, calling it Cocoa-Cola
朱迪说，这本配方书最初属于埃文斯。她说书里到处都是他的名字。显然，在他的朋友彭伯顿发明了可乐后，埃文斯把配方抄写在这本书里，称之为“Cocoa-Cola”。
That's right.
没错。
And after Evans died, the book started its travels.
埃文斯去世后，这本书就开始了它的漂流记。
Evans gave it to RM Mitchell from Griffin, Georgia. And then Mitchell's widow was a friend of my husband's and told him, after he passed way, to come over and get any books he wanted to out of the library. So Everett picked out the book.
埃文斯把它给了乔治亚州格里芬市的RM·米切尔（RM Mitchell）。然后米切尔的遗孀是我丈夫的朋友，在他（我丈夫）去世后，她告诉他，去图书馆拿任何他想要的书。所以埃弗里特选了那本书。
What's it look like?
它看起来什么样？
Oh gosh, it's 133 years old. It's just leather bound. And I wear gloves-- the last time I looked at it, I like to wear gloves.
噢天哪，它有133岁了。只是装订在皮革里。我戴着手套——上次看它的时候，我喜欢戴上手套。
Everett was so intrigued by the Coke recipe that he spent the last year of his life while he struggled with cancer researching and writing his own book, a history of the inventor of Coca-Cola, that's still unpublished.
埃弗里特对可乐配方非常着迷，以至于他在生命的最后一年，在与癌症抗争的同时，研究并撰写了自己的书，一本关于可口可乐发明者的历史，至今尚未出版。
Interestingly, just like the characters in Lord of the Rings when they get a hold of the ring, once Everett had the secret formula, like the people at Coca-Cola, he started to get protective. The recipe book now sits in a bank vault. Take his reaction when his fishing buddy, Charles, did the 1979 newspaper story about the recipe book. the newspaper published a photo that was big enough that you can read all the ingredients and the amounts, the entire recipe.
有趣的是，就像《指环王》里的角色拿到戒指一样，一旦埃弗里特拿到了秘密配方，就像可口可乐公司的人一样，他开始变得警惕起来。这本配方书现在锁在银行金库里。看看当他的钓鱼伙伴查尔斯在1979年发表关于这本配方书的报纸文章时，他的反应。报纸刊登了一张大到足以读出所有成分和用量的照片，整个配方都在上面。
See, Charles did that, and Everett was unhappy about that.
你看，查尔斯那样做了，埃弗里特对此很不高兴。
Oh, he was?
噢，是吗？
But I won't go into that.
但我不想深入谈论那个。
Oh, really?
噢，真的吗？
Yeah.
是的。
And was he happy that there was an article?
那他对文章的发表感到高兴吗？
Yeah, but not the formula page.
是的，但配方那一页除外。
Oh, here it is. Yeah, so I'm looking at it here.
噢，在这儿呢。是的，我正在看。
We sent a copy of that photo where you can see the recipe for Coca-Cola to that historian of Coca-Cola, the guy who wrote that book, Mark Pendergrast.
我们把那张能看清可口可乐配方的照片寄给了那位可口可乐历史学家，就是写那本书的马克·彭德格拉斯特。
And my question for you is, could this be real?
我想问你的是，这可能是真的吗？
Yeah. I think that it certainly is a version of the formula. And it's very, very similar to the formula that I found that I talked about and printed in the back of my book.
是的。我认为这绝对是配方的一个版本。而且它和我发现的、我在书的后部谈到并印刷出来的配方非常、非常相似。
This was an amazing discovery. In Mark's book he tells the story of looking through Coca-Cola's archives and being shown the yellowing pages of an old notebook that belonged to the inventor of Coca-Cola, John Pemberton. The Coke people told him that it was from way before Pemberton moved to Atlanta, way before he invented Coke.
这是一个了不起的发现。在马克的书中，他讲述了查阅可口可乐档案并被展示一本属于可口可乐发明者约翰·彭伯顿的旧笔记本发黄页面的故事。可乐的人告诉他，那是彭伯顿搬到亚特兰大之前、远在他发明可乐之前的东西。
But in fact, it was quite clear that it was a formula book from at least after he'd invented Coca-Cola, because it mentioned Coca-Cola.
但事实上，很明显那是一本至少在发明可口可乐之后的配方书，因为它提到了可口可乐。
Oh, so do you think they just didn't know?
噢，所以你认为他们只是不知道？
Apparently not. So in this formula book there was a piece of paper that had a big X on the top of it. And as I looked at it, I thought, I saw this flavoring ingredient. It had neroli. It had coriander. I though, my God. This is a Coca-Cola formula. I couldn't believe it.
显然不知道。所以在这本配方书里，有一张纸，顶部画了一个大大的X。当我看着它时，我想，我看到了这种调味成分。它有橙花油。它有芫荽。我想，天哪。这就是可口可乐的配方。我简直不敢相信。
And did the company confirm that that's what this was?
公司证实这是配方了吗？
Of course not. The company denies that that's what it was.
当然没有。公司否认这就是配方。
New York Times May 2, 1993, the year Mark's book was published, Coca-Cola calls the recipe in his book, quote, "The latest in a long line of previous unsuccessful attempts to reveal a 107 year old mystery."
1993年5月2日《纽约时报》，即马克那本书出版的那一年，可口可乐公司称书中的配方为，“一长串先前试图揭开107年神秘面纱但不成功的尝试中的最新一个”。
But here's where things get interesting. When you compare these two recipes, the one that Mark found in John Pemberton's own notebook, stored deep inside Coca-Cola's very own archives, and the one from the 1979 newspaper clipping found 40 miles away in Griffin, Georgia--
但有趣的地方来了。当你对比这两个配方时，一个是马克在约翰·彭伯顿自己的笔记本中发现的，储存在可口可乐档案深处，另一个是从40英里外乔治亚州格里芬发现的1979年的剪报——
Oil of lemon.
柠檬油。
--not only do they match up ingredient for ingredient, identical--
——不仅成分与成分完全匹配，一模一样——
Oil of coriander.
芫荽油。
--the recipe in the newspaper fills in things that the one in the Coke archive leaves blank. The recipe from Coke's archive just lists numbers next to each ingredient. But the newspaper says what the numbers stand for: ounces and drops and drams. The recipe that was found in Coke's archive is just labeled X. The newspaper one says clearly, this recipe is Cocoa-Cola.
——报纸上的配方补全了可乐档案中留下的空白。可乐档案中的配方在每种成分旁边只列出了数字。但报纸写明了这些数字代表什么：盎司、滴和打兰（drams）。在可乐档案中发现的配方只标记为X。报纸上的那个清楚地写着，这个配方是可口可乐。
I got into this wondering if it might be possible that this super secret recipe had been hiding in plain sight in an old newspaper clipping for decades. But once I learned that it actually matched this recipe in Coke's own archives, written by the creator of Coke, it was hard not to get very excited. These last two weeks I've been carrying around a printout of the recipe everywhere I go, this one that I have right here with me in the studio today. And I've been telling everybody I see, I think I may have found the secret formula for Coke. And then I just watch them freak out.
我开始研究这个问题时想知道，这个超级秘密的配方是否几十年来一直躲在旧报纸剪报中。但一旦我得知它确实与可乐自己档案中、由可乐创造者书写的配方匹配，就很难不感到非常兴奋。过去两周，我一直随身带着这份配方的打印件，就是我现在在工作室里的这份。我见到谁都说，我觉得我可能找到了可乐的秘密配方。然后我就看着他们抓狂。
So now, right here on the radio, I will read you the formula. You have heard the facts. You can draw your own conclusions as to what this is.
所以现在，就在广播里，我给你们读一下这个配方。你们听到了事实。至于这是什么，你们可以自己得出结论。
Oh, wait, but first--
噢，等等，先等等——
Is it legal for us to even talk about this on the radio? Is Coke going to sue us both?
我们在广播里谈论这个合法吗？可乐会起诉我们两人吗？
No, I don't think they will. Because if they sued anything pertaining to the formula, then they would have to then produce the formula in order to say that what you were doing was an infringement on their formula. And they will never do that.
不，我不认为他们会。因为如果他们起诉任何与该配方有关的事情，那么他们就必须拿出配方，以证明你们所做的是侵犯了他们的配方。他们永远不会这样做。
Great. Here we go. The 7x formula is just one element in these two recipes. It's made from 20 drops of orange oil, 30 of lemon oil, 10 of nutmeg oil, 5 of coriander oil, 10 of neroli oil-- neroli's a kind of orangey flavor-- 10 of cinnamon oil, and 8 ounces of alcohol. You mix that together, and then you take a little bit of that flavoring. One recipe says two ounces, the other says two and a half. You put that into another container where you're going to mix the syrup for the soda.
太好了。我们开始吧。7x配方只是这两个配方中的一个元素。它由20滴橙油，30滴柠檬油，10滴肉豆蔻油，5滴芫荽油，10滴橙花油——橙花是一种橙味香料——10滴肉桂油和8盎司酒精制成。你把这些混合在一起，然后取少量调味剂。一个配方说两盎司，另一个说两盎司半。你把它放入另一个容器，在那里混合汽水糖浆。
The other ingredients, 3 ounces citric acid, 1 ounce caffeine, 2 and a 1/2 gallons of water. The recipe calls that aqua. 2 pints of lime juice, an ounce of vanilla, 1 and 1/2 ounces of caramel coloring. And then we arrive at the two most controversial ingredients in Coca-Cola. 30 pounds of sugar-- pounds-- and at the very top of the page, first ingredient, FE coca, which stands for fluid extract of coca. That'll be the flavor of the coca leaf, which includes a small amount of cocaine.
其他成分：3盎司柠檬酸，1盎司咖啡因，2.5加仑水。配方称之为“水”（aqua）。2品脱青柠汁，一盎司香草，1.5盎司焦糖色素。然后我们来到了可口可乐中两个最具争议的成分。30磅糖——磅——而在页面最顶部，第一个成分，FE coca，代表古柯流浸膏。那就是古柯叶的味道，其中包含少量可卡因。
In fact, Mark says that cocaine figures in a big way in the creation of Coca-Cola. Before he invented Coke, John Pemberton had a hit with another drink called French Wine Coca. It's ingredients: wine, cocaine, and caffeine. Hard to see why people went for that one, right?
事实上，马克说可卡因在可口可乐的创造中起到了很大的作用。在发明可乐之前，约翰·彭伯顿有一种叫“法国红酒可乐”的畅销饮料。其成分：红酒、可卡因和咖啡因。很难理解为什么人们会喜欢那个，对吧？
Then, in 1885, Atlanta voted for prohibition, and Pemberton realized that he was going to have to get rid of the wine in his bestselling drink. So he kept the two other ingredients, the cocaine and the caffeine. People loved those. But when you mix cocaine and caffeine together, they're bitter. So he pours in a ton of sugar to cut the bitterness and voila, Coca-Cola. Pemberton called it his temperance drink.
然后，1885年，亚特兰大投票通过禁酒令，彭伯顿意识到他必须去掉畅销饮料中的红酒。所以他保留了另外两种成分，可卡因和咖啡因。人们喜欢这些。但当你把可卡因和咖啡因混合在一起时，它们是苦的。所以他倒入大量的糖来掩盖苦味，瞧，可口可乐。彭伯顿称之为他的禁酒饮料。
I mean, this is an interesting thing. They still do use coca leaf for Coke, but they decocainize it in Maywood, New Jersey at the Stepan Chemical Company, which was--
我的意思是，这是一个有趣的事情。他们仍然使用古柯叶制作可乐，但他们在纽泽西州梅伍德的Stepan化学公司对其进行了脱可卡因处理，该公司是——
Wait. So there's a plant in New Jersey, and basically they import tons and tons of coca leaves. They remove the cocaine from the coca leaf?
等等。所以纽泽西有一个工厂，基本上他们进口成吨成吨的古柯叶。他们从古柯叶中去掉了可卡因？
Correct. And it's been decocainized there since 1903.
正确。自1903年以来，它就在那里进行了脱可卡因处理。
1903 being the year that Coca-Cola rids itself of cocaine. So there's all this circumstantial evidence pointing to this recipe being the original recipe for Coca-Cola. Or at any rate, one of the original recipes. But the only way to tell for sure would be to make a batch. Taste it. The historian had never done that, the columnist back in 1979 never did it. That would be the final test. So we set out to do it.
1903年是可口可乐摆脱可卡因的年份。所以所有的间接证据都指向这个配方是可口可乐的原始配方。或者至少，是原始配方之一。但要确定的唯一方法是制作一批。尝尝它。那位历史学家从未这样做过，1979年的那位专栏作家也从未这样做过。那将是最终的测试。所以我们着手去做。
This is it. This is it at the top, the first one up there.
就是这个。顶部第一个就是这个。
First obstacle in our path, kind of a huge one-- coca leaves are a Schedule II controlled substance. Totally illegal in the United States. When we asked the company that brings them in under special federal supervision and decocainizes them for Coca-Cola, this company Stepan, and asked them to sell us some, they stopped returning our calls. No coca leaves, no way to make the secret recipe.
我们道路上的第一个障碍，相当巨大——古柯叶是附表二管制物质。在美国完全是非法的。当我们询问在特殊联邦监督下进口古柯叶并为可口可乐进行脱可卡因处理的公司Stepan，并要求他们卖给我们一些时，他们停止回复我们的电话。没有古柯叶，就无法制作秘密配方。
But then, my fellow This American Life producer Ben Calhoun turned to an obscure back alley resource called the internet.
但后来，我的《美国生活》制片人同事本·卡尔霍恩（Ben Calhoun）转向了一个默默无闻的后巷资源，即互联网。
Wow, look at this. I just typed coca tea into the search. 5, 6, 7-- there's like a dozen things. More than a dozen, 15, 20 things come up which are coca tea just in amazon.com.
哇，看这个。我刚在搜索栏输入了“古柯茶”。5、6、7——大概有十几个东西。不止十几个，15、20个东西跳了出来，都是亚马逊网站上的古柯茶。
So the way that Coke does it with taking the cocaine out, this company says that they do the same thing.
所以可乐去掉可卡因的方式，这家公司说他们做的是同样的事情。
So the hardest part was done, except for making the soda. For that we turned to professionals.
所以最困难的部分完成了，除了制作汽水。为此我们求助于专业人士。
When we first sent you guys this recipe and you took a look at it, can I just ask you, what did you think when you saw the ingredients?
当我们第一次把这个配方发给你们看时，我可以问一下吗，当你们看到这些成分时你们是怎么想的？
It was pretty dizzying for me.
对我来说这相当令人头晕。
Yeah, I mean it took a little while to sort of translate the handwriting and figure out what it was.
是的，我的意思是花了一点时间来翻译手写内容并弄清楚它是什么。
Meet Eric Chastain and Mike Spear, respectively the VP of operations and the marketing director at Jones Soda in Seattle. Jones makes it living on flavors like cream soda and green apple soda. But they're also known for being willing to try anything. They have made turkey and gravy soda, they've made Brussels sprout soda. We sent them our recipe, and by the time that Ben and I got to their office, Mike and Eric had already made up a couple bottles of our recipe and were ready for a taste test. Our stuff versus real Coca-Cola.
认识一下西雅图Jones Soda公司的运营副总裁埃里克·查斯顿（Eric Chastain）和营销总监迈克·斯皮尔（Mike Spear）。Jones靠奶油苏打和青苹果汽水之类的口味维持生计。但他们也以愿意尝试任何事情而闻名。他们做过火鸡和肉汁汽水，做过抱子甘蓝汽水。我们把配方发给了他们，当本和我到达他们的办公室时，迈克和埃里克已经按照我们的配方做了几瓶汽水，准备进行口味测试。我们的东西对比真正的可口可乐。
This is the first bottle of Coke we've ever had in this office.
这是我们办公室里有史以来第一瓶可乐。
Just get it out as soon as we can.
尽快把它弄出去。
Yeah, just get rid of it.
是的，把它弄走。
We were worried that asking you guys to go out and make Coca-Cola was like asking you to like go into the Death Star and blow up some planets or something.
我们担心要求你们出去制作可口可乐就像要求你们进入死星并炸毁一些行星之类的。
There was a little debate over that.
关于这一点有一点争论。
There was a debate. Yeah, for sure.
确实有争论。是的，肯定的。
[POURING]
[倒酒声]
First, samples from our soda, the one from the 1979 newspaper, are poured into little cups. We're instructed to sniff first, then take a small sip, roll it around in our mouths. We really do not know what to expect.
首先，我们把报纸配方制作的汽水样品倒进小杯子里。我们被指示先闻，然后啜饮一小口，在嘴里回味。我们真的不知道会发生什么。
I have this feeling like I'm going to drop acid right now.
我有一种感觉，好像我现在要嗑药了。
It's kind of tasty.
这味道还不错。
It is kind of tasty. It's not bad. It's definitely got a medicinal note to it.
这味道还挺好的。不算坏。它确实带有一种药味。
Yeah, it does.
是的，确实。
I find it to be really mediciney. And if you didn't tell me that this was the Coca-Cola recipe, I wouldn't have known. It tastes fruity.
我发现它真的很像药。如果你不告诉我这就是可口可乐的配方，我根本不知道。它尝起来有水果味。
Yeah.
是的。
It does taste a little fruity.
它确实尝起来有点水果味。
Ben says the flavor is like Froot Loops. To me, it's more like orange-flavored baby aspirin. Which means, we failed, right? We made the recipe. You would never mistake it for Coca-Cola. But then it occurred to us, maybe the original version of Coca-Cola did not taste like Coke today.
本说这味道像“水果圈”麦片。对我来说，它更像橙味的婴儿阿司匹林。这意味着，我们失败了，对吧？我们制作了配方。你绝对不会把它错当成可口可乐。但后来我们想到，也许可口可乐的原始版本尝起来并不像现在的可乐。
Charles Candler, that guy who was taken into the holy of holies to learn the secret recipe from his dad, wrote this, "The Pemberton product--" that is the original product-- "did not have an altogether agreeable taste. It was unstable. It contained too many things. Too much of some ingredients and too little of others. The bouquet of several of the volatile essential oils previously used was adversely affected by some ingredients."
查尔斯·坎德勒，那个被带进圣殿向父亲学习秘密配方的人，写道：“彭伯顿的产品——就是最初的产品——口感并不完全令人愉快。它不稳定。它包含的东西太多了。某些成分太多，某些太少。以前使用过的几种挥发性精油的香气受到某些成分的不利影响。”
That could be the lime and baby aspirin flavored mess that we had just tried. But there was another possibility. The soda guys thought that technology has gotten so much better at extracting flavors like orange oil and lemon oil from fruits in the last 125 years, it's possible that all our ingredients are much, much stronger than Pemberton worked with back in 1886.
这可能是我们刚才尝试的那种青柠和婴儿阿司匹林味的东西。但还有另一种可能。汽水专家认为，在过去125年中，从水果中提取橙油和柠檬油等口味的技术已经进步了很多，我们所有的原料可能比彭伯顿在1886年使用的要强得多、强得多。
David Ames.
大卫·艾姆斯（David Ames）。
David, it's Eric and the rest of the gang at Jones.
大卫，我是Jones公司的埃里克和大家。
So Eric and Mike called the flavor company that they're working on with all this-- it's a company that specializes in beverage flavors called Sovereign down in Orange County, California-- and asked if they could do a version that tones down the citrus and other flavors.
所以埃里克和迈克给他们合作的调味公司打了电话——那是一家专门从事饮料口味的公司，叫Sovereign，位于加州橙县——问他们是否能做一个调低柑橘和其他口味的版本。
Maybe reduce, I don't know, maybe 5, 10%.
也许减少，我不知道，也许5%、10%。
OK, got it.
好的，明白了。
[BOTTLES JANGLING]
[瓶子碰撞声]
Chemicals are all over here.
化学药品到处都是。
A few hours later we have flown south to Los Angeles. We are in Sovereign's lab, a room that smells like you're inside a bag of jelly beans. And we do a second taste test.
几个小时后，我们飞往南方的洛杉矶。我们在Sovereign的实验室里，一个闻起来就像在一个果冻豆袋子里的房间。我们进行了第二次口味测试。
All right, so we've got the revised cola on the left and then Coca-Cola on the right.
好了，所以左边是修改后的可乐，右边是可口可乐。
In the lab with us and Mike from Jones Soda were David Ames, who runs the flavor company, and his staff. Going with the idea that our essential oils were much stronger than Pemberton's, they ended up cutting the amount of flavor in half. And then they tried it and they thought, oh, let's cut it in half again.
在实验室和我们在一起的，还有Jones Soda的迈克，大卫·艾姆斯（经营调味公司的人）和他的员工。考虑到我们的精油比彭伯顿时代的强得多，他们最终将调味量减半。然后他们尝试了，觉得，噢，让我们再减半一次。
It's interesting. It's definitely more mellow.
有趣。它肯定更醇厚了。
But also, the flavor profile is almost at the same intensity as the Coke flavor profile.
但同时，口味特征与可乐的口味特征强度几乎相同。
I feel like you guy just knocked off Fort Knox.
我觉得你们刚刚洗劫了诺克斯堡。
We look at each other like, what had we done?
我们互相对视，想知道我们做了什么？
How close do you think you are to the taste of actual Coca-Cola now?
你觉得你现在离真正的可口可乐口感有多近？
I would say probably, what, on a the scale of 10? We're probably around 9, I would say. 8 and 1/2, 9.
我想大概，在1到10的尺度上？我们大概在9左右，我想。8.5，9。
Later I talked to Steve Warth, the guy who did the heavy lifting in converting that old formula into modern lab measurements. He's the one in charge of developing Sovereign's flavors. He says the ingredients in this old recipe were no surprise to him. Most of them are the same ingredients you use to make any cola.
后来我和史蒂夫·沃斯（Steve Warth）谈了话，就是那个将旧配方转换为现代实验室测量标准进行繁重工作的人。他是负责开发Sovereign口味的人。他说，这个旧配方中的成分对他来说并不稀奇。大多数成分和制作任何可乐使用的成分一样。
Orange oil, lemon oil, nutmeg, and cinnamon would be the main ones. I noticed that the neroli and the coriander seemed higher than what I've seen elsewhere.
橙油、柠檬油、肉豆蔻和肉桂应该是主要的。我注意到橙花和芫荽的用量似乎比我在其他地方看到的要高。
Steve said that if we ever decided to match Coca-Cola the way it tastes today, lots of things about the formula are widely known. We'd have to replace the citric acid in the old formula with phosphoric acid. That's what modern sodas use. We would replace the lime juice with lime oil. We'd swap this sugar for high fructose corn syrup.
史蒂夫说，如果我们决定匹配今天可口可乐的口感，配方的很多东西都是众所周知的。我们将不得不把旧配方中的柠檬酸替换为磷酸。那是现代汽水使用的东西。我们将用青柠油替换青柠汁。我们会用高果糖玉米糖浆替换这里的糖。
I know in some of the other flavor companies that I've worked at, we've worked on trying to get as close. We've had customers that come in and say, I want an exact match for Coke. And they're usually pretty close.
我知道我在其他一些调味公司工作时，我们曾尝试尽可能地接近。我们有客户进来说，我想要完全匹配可乐。它们通常相当接近。
So basically, this idea of Coke, it's the super secret thing that nobody could crack, from your perspective, that's just some very cheerful showmanship on their part.
所以基本上，这个可乐是没人能破解的超级机密的想法，在你的视角里，那只是他们方面非常欢快的表演而已。
Well, actually, no. It isn't. If you wanted to go side by side and match it exactly, that's very difficult. And that's not only difficult for Coca-Cola, it's difficult for everything.
嗯，事实上，不。不是。如果你想并排比较并完全匹配它，那是非常困难的。这不仅对可口可乐公司来说很难，对任何事情来说都很难。
That's because even if you know that there's say, cinnamon, in a drink, you don't know where it came from-- Sri Lanka, Indonesia. And that can make all the difference in the flavor. I asked the flavor guys at Sovereign if they could pick out the real Coca-Cola from our formula in a blind taste test.
那是因为即使你知道饮料里有肉桂，你也不知道它来自哪里——斯里兰卡、印度尼西亚。那在味道上可以产生所有的差异。我问Sovereign的调味专家，他们是否能在盲测中从我们的配方中挑出真正的可口可乐。
I'd be able to tell.
我能分辨出来。
Yeah, there's probably a good chance that we will. Yes.
是的，很有可能我们会分辨出来。是的。
So we marked the little plastic cups which had real Coca-Cola with a Sharpie, just a little dot on the bottom of the cup. The cups with our formula had no dot. Everyone tasted. David, the guy who runs the company, was sure that he was drinking our formula. And then he flipped over the cup and saw--
所以我们在装有真正可口可乐的小塑料杯上用记号笔做了标记，杯底有一个小点。装有我们配方的杯子没有点。每个人都尝了。经营公司的老板大卫确信他在喝我们的配方。然后他翻开杯子一看——
Sharpie. I got a Sharpie.
记号笔。我有记号笔。
Meaning he thought our formula was Coca-Cola.
意思是，他以为我们的配方是可口可乐。
I got a Sharpie.
我拿到了记号笔。
Do you think ordinary consumers would be able to pick out which one of these is real Coca-Cola?
你认为普通消费者能分辨出哪一个是真正的可口可乐吗？
I highly doubt it. I seriously doubt that. I think if we would do a blind test right now with a regular consumer, I think we will be able to fool them.
我很怀疑。我严重怀疑。我想如果我们现在对普通消费者进行盲测，我想我们能骗过他们。
Attention all [INAUDIBLE] shoppers. Take a moment to look down at your shopping carts. You may have the wrong cart. If you have the wrong cart, please return it to the [INAUDIBLE] department. Thank you.
各位[听不清]顾客请注意。花点时间看一眼你们的购物车。你们可能拿错了车。如果你拿错了车，请把它还给[听不清]部门。谢谢。
Ben and I put on lab coats and we set up a table in aisle 2B of a supermarket one afternoon with bottles of our soda-- that is, the formula from the 1979 newspaper article-- and Coca-Cola. Taste test time.
本和我穿上实验服，一天下午在超市的2B过道摆了一张桌子，上面放着我们的汽水瓶——也就是来自1979年报纸文章的配方——和可口可乐。口味测试时间到了。
One of the first people who came up to us was actually a woman who had worked supermarket tastings herself.
走过来的人中，第一个人其实是一位自己也做过超市品尝工作的女性。
Use your smiles. People love to see a smile. And when you get a smile back, that's when you're like, hey, you want to [SNAP] try a sample? That's how you know.
多笑笑。人们喜欢看到微笑。当你得到回馈的微笑时，那就是你觉得，嘿，你想[响指]试个样品吗？就是这样。
Do I have to make the [SNAP] sound?
我必须发出[响指]声音吗？
No, you don't have to. That's what I do sometimes.
不，你不需要。有时我就是这么做的。
So Ben and I smiled. With each person we would give them our formula first.
所以本和我微笑着。对于每个人，我们首先给他们我们的配方。
I taste berries.
我尝到了浆果的味道。
And then we gave a real Coke second.
然后我们第二次给他们真正的可乐。
Tastes like RC Cola.
尝起来像RC可乐。
Tastes like a really cheap cola.
尝起来像非常便宜的可乐。
And before we told people what they were, we asked which they liked better.
在告诉人们它们是什么之前，我们问他们更喜欢哪一个。
I liked the first one better.
我更喜欢第一个。
Probably the second one.
可能是第二个吧。
Second one?
第二个？
Yeah, the second one I prefer.
是的，我更喜欢第二个。
60% of the people preferred our formula over Coca-Cola.
60%的人更喜欢我们的配方而不是可口可乐。
The first one.
第一个。
Though, to be fair to Coca-Cola, people who said they drank a lot of soft drinks, they always preferred the Coke.
虽然说句公道话，对于可口可乐来说，那些说自己经常喝软饮料的人，他们总是更喜欢可乐。
It's better than the first one.
它比第一个好。
And when we asked people to guess which of the two drinks was Coca-Cola, to our surprise actually, of the 30 people that we polled, 28 could tell which was Coca-Cola. Our formula was that different. People saw a family resemblance though.
当我们要求人们猜哪两种饮料是可口可乐时，令我们惊讶的是，在接受调查的30个人中，有28个人能分辨出哪个是可口可乐。我们的配方太不一样了。不过人们确实看出了家族相似性。
I was thinking it taste more like the old vanilla Coke.
我觉得它更像老式的香草可乐。
It had an aftertaste that made me stop and think for a minute. But I tell it was somewhere in there or was manufactured by Coke.
它有一种余味，让我停下来想了一会儿。但我能看出来它在某处或者是由可乐生产的。
It tastes like weird soda trying to be Coke.
它尝起来像古怪的汽水试图成为可乐。
There was just one more person that I wanted to taste the soda that we made and look at the recipe. And that was the Coca-Cola's corporation resident expert on the history of the product and its early formulas.
还有一个人我想让他尝尝我们制作的汽水并看看这个配方。那就是可口可乐公司内部关于产品及其早期配方历史的常驻专家。
My Name is Phil Mooney. I'm the archivist for the Coca-Cola company based in Atlanta, Georgia. My quick reaction is that it's sweeter and flatter than Coca-Cola. It doesn't have what we call the bite and the burn that Coca-Cola has.
我叫菲尔·穆尼（Phil Mooney）。我是可口可乐公司的档案管理员，位于乔治亚州亚特兰大。我很快的反应是它比可口可乐更甜、更平淡。它没有我们所说的可口可乐那种“冲击感和灼烧感”。
Does this seem like it could be an ancestor or a relative of Coca-Cola?
这看起来像是可口可乐的祖先或亲戚吗？
You know, quite frankly I don't think so.
你知道，坦率地说，我不这么认为。
I told Phil everything that we knew about the recipe-- the newspaper article it came from, how it matched a recipe deep in his own archives. He was not impressed. Very, very not impressed.
我把我们知道的关于配方的一切都告诉了菲尔——它来自的报纸文章，它是如何与他自己档案深处的配方匹配的。他并没有被打动。非常、非常没有被打动。
And really, this is not unusual. I can't tell you how many people have come forward over the years and claimed to have the formula for Coca-Cola. I probably have three or four dozen examples of that. And they'll say, well, I knew this old pharmacist-- almost the same story that you told me. And he got this recipe from a friend, usually it's a friend of Asa Candler or John Pemberton.
而且真的，这并不罕见。我数不清这些年来有多少人站出来声称拥有可口可乐的配方。我大概有三四十个这样的例子。他们会说，嗯，我认识一位老药剂师——几乎和你告诉我的故事一模一样。他从一个朋友那里得到了这个配方，通常是阿萨·坎德勒或约翰·彭伯顿的朋友。
And do most of them have these same ingredients? They have lime, and they have neroli and cinnamon and nutmeg?
他们大多数人都有这些相同的成分吗？他们有青柠、橙花、肉桂和肉豆蔻吗？
Almost all of them are very, very similar, if not identical.
几乎所有人都是非常、非常相似，如果不说完全相同的话。
We went around and around on this. To me, the fact that the recipe showed up over and over gave it credibility. Coke's inventor John Pemberton was known to have sold the recipe to several different people back in the early days. And the fact that it had appeared in his own notebook in Coke's archive seemed like the clincher.
我们反复讨论这个问题。对我来说，配方一次又一次出现的事实赋予了它可信度。可乐的发明者约翰·彭伯顿在早期是众所周知的，他把配方卖给了几个不同的人。而且它出现在他自己位于可乐档案的笔记本中，似乎是决定性的因素。
But Phil said that no, no, that notebook, if we were to look at it more closely, was full of all kinds of failed attempts at soda recipes and variations on recipes. So it was hard for him to believe that the real formula for Coke was stuck in there among that stuff.
但菲尔说不，不，如果我们仔细看看那本笔记本，里面全是各种失败的汽水配方尝试和配方变体。所以他很难相信可乐的真实配方就夹在那些东西里。
Could it be a precursor? Yeah. Absolutely. Is this one that went to market? I don't think so.
它可能是前身吗？是的。绝对是。这是上市的版本吗？我不这么认为。
But we don't know?
但我们不知道？
We're pretty sure. We're pretty sure that the final recipe was not the one represented in that book.
我们很确定。我们很确定最终的配方不是书中记载的那个。
I asked him if anybody at Coca-Cola who had access to the original recipe, which he says they still have, actually checked to see if it matched the one in that notebook. And he politely side-stepped that question and we moved on.
我问他，可口可乐内部是否有任何可以接触到原始配方的人（他说他们确实还有）去核实过它是否与笔记本中的匹配。他礼貌地避开了这个问题，然后我们继续谈话。
And there's all this fuss about the secret formula, but it seems like the basic ingredients of Coca-Cola are actually on the public record.
关于秘密配方，所有的争论似乎都在这里，但可口可乐的基本成分似乎确实是公开记录的。
Absolutely.
绝对是。
So we put it to him. Was the secret formula really a secret? He said that even if somebody cracked the entire manufacturing process, which he said they'd have to do, and produce something very, very close, Coke has this whole of this thing nobody can touch.
所以我们问了他。秘密配方真的是秘密吗？他说，即使有人破解了整个制造过程（他说他们必须这样做）并生产出非常、非常接近的东西，可乐还有这个没人能触碰的东西。
There's a psychological element to this product. We've got a 125 years worth of marketing and advertising. And people's memories.
这个产品有心理因素。我们有125年的营销和广告。还有人们的记忆。
Well in the supermarket, when we were in the supermarket, one of the young women who tasted the product, she tasted an unmarked little cup of Coca-Cola and she said, "That tastes like my childhood."
嗯，在超市里，当我们在超市时，尝过产品的年轻女性之一，她尝了一小杯未标记的可口可乐，她说：“那尝起来像我的童年。”
There you go.
你看，就是这样。
That's what 125 years of omnipresent worldwide distribution and promotion buys you. I told Phil that we were going to put up the old recipe that we found on our website and asked him if it would be OK with Coke if listeners would try to make batches themselves-- all the ingredients and oils that you need are online. They're cheap too. And he laughed and said, "Yeah. Yeah, let them try. They'll come running back to Coke."
这就是125年无处不在的全球分销和推广所换来的。我告诉菲尔，我们打算把我们找到的旧配方放在我们的网站上，并问他如果听众自己尝试制作，可乐方是否同意——你需要的所有原料和油都在网上。而且它们很便宜。他笑了笑说：“是的。是的，让他们试试吧。他们会跑回可乐怀抱的。”
Coming up, how much does one of President Obama's old spark plugs sell for, and the search for other historical originals. In a minute, from Chicago Public Radio and Public Radio International when our program continues.
即将到来的是，奥巴马总统的旧火花塞能卖多少钱，以及对其他原始历史物品的搜寻。一分钟后，来自芝加哥公共广播电台和公共广播国际公司，我们的节目继续。
It's This American Life . I'm Ira Glass. Today's show, "Original Recipe." Stories of people going to great lengths to find the authentic original item. We have arrived at act two of our show. Act two, "Ask not what your handwriting analyst can do for you; ask what you can do for your handwriting analyst."
这是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。今天的节目是“原始配方”。关于人们为了寻找真正的原始物品而不遗余力的故事。我们已经到了节目的第二幕。第二幕，“不要问你的笔迹分析师能为你做什么；问问你能为你的笔迹分析师做什么。”
When you find an old, authentic original it can, of course, mean lots and lots of money. Jake Halpern tells what happened when somebody stumbled onto a trove of astounding papers, which lots of people thought was worth millions.
当你找到一个古老、真实、原始的东西时，它当然可能意味着很多很多的钱。杰克·哈珀恩（Jake Halpern）讲述了当有人偶然发现一批令人震惊的文件时发生了什么，很多人认为这些文件价值连城。
John Reznikoff buys and sells relics and documents. He's got a sprawling office in Westport, Connecticut that's floor to ceiling history. Old documents hanging everywhere signed by Thomas Jefferson or James Madison or John Hancock. He's got Abraham Lincoln's spectacles in a file cabinet. And in the middle of the room, as if some movers just dumped it there, something that looks like an old school desk.
约翰·雷兹尼科夫（John Reznikoff）买卖文物和文件。他在康涅狄格州韦斯特波特有一间巨大的办公室，墙上挂满了历史。到处都是旧文件，上面有托马斯·杰斐逊、詹姆斯·麦迪逊或约翰·汉考克的签名。他在档案柜里有亚伯拉罕·林肯的眼镜。在房间中央，仿佛是搬运工刚把它扔在那儿，看起来像一张老式学校课桌。
That's Abraham Lincoln's desk. And why is it sitting here? Good question. I need to get it restored.
那是亚伯拉罕·林肯的课桌。为什么它坐在这里？好问题。我需要让人修复它。
By the way, $325,000, if you're interested. In a back room there's Annie Oakley's gun leaning up against the shelf where Earnest Hemingway's typewriter sits, alongside Franklin Roosevelt's chess set. It's like what you'd see if the Smithsonian had a going out of business sale. The strangest thing that he bought and sold recently was President Obama's old Jeep. It helped that Obama had mentioned the car in a speech at Chrysler.
顺便说一句，如果你感兴趣的话，32.5万美元。在后屋里，有安妮·奥克利的枪靠在放着欧内斯特·海明威打字机的架子上，旁边是富兰克林·罗斯福的象棋。这就像如果史密森尼博物馆大甩卖你会看到的样子。他最近买卖的最奇怪的东西是奥巴马总统的旧吉普车。这得益于奥巴马在克莱斯勒的一次演讲中提到了这辆车。
And I put a little clip of that on a YouTube video. And I'll do my best Obama impersonation. "My first car was a Jeep Grand Cherokee. I loved that car."
我把它的一小段视频放到了YouTube上。我尽量模仿一下奥巴马。“我的第一辆车是吉普大切诺基。我喜欢那辆车。”
It sold for a lot, though John wouldn't say how much. When the guy who bought it had it repaired, John asked if he could keep the spare parts. He stores them in a closet in his office.
它卖了很多钱，尽管约翰没说卖了多少。当买下它的人去修理时，约翰问他是否可以留下零件。他把它们存在办公室的壁橱里。
I'm not kidding, right. So I guess these are struts. Those are Obama's struts. And [RUMMAGING] in the bottom-- here, I'll grab a spark plug. There. There's a spark plug from Obama's car. I actually just sold one of these for $500 because it was Obama's.
我没开玩笑。所以我想这些是支柱。那是奥巴马的支柱。在底部[翻找]——给你，我拿个火花塞。在那。这是奥巴马车上的火花塞。我刚把其中一个卖了500美元，因为它是奥巴马的。
Sucker, right? $500 for a spark plug? But five minutes in John's office and you realize, people will buy anything connected to historical figures, assuming it's real.
傻瓜，对吧？500美元买一个火花塞？但在约翰的办公室呆五分钟，你就会意识到，人们会买任何与历史人物有关的东西，前提是它是真的。
This business, especially the rare document business, can be risky. There are so many fakes out there. So John is a fanatic about authenticity. He's studied fakes to see how they're made. He owns a huge collection of forgeries he bought from another collector and he uses it as a reference. He can sometimes even identify a particular forger. And part of his office looks like a lab on CSI. He's got a special high-powered magnifier called a proscope, and a video spectral comparator, a $30,000 machine used to analyze ink.
这个业务，特别是稀有文献业务，风险很大。外面有太多赝品了。所以约翰对真实性非常狂热。他研究赝品以了解它们是如何制作的。他拥有从另一位收藏家那里买来的巨大伪造品收藏，并将其作为参考。他有时甚至能识别出特定的伪造者。他的办公室的一部分看起来像CSI的实验室。他有一个特殊的强力放大镜叫Proscope，和一个视频光谱比较仪，一台价值3万美元的机器，用于分析墨水。
John's called as an expert witness on handwriting in all kinds of court cases. He's a go-to guy in his field for spotting fake autographs.
约翰被传唤作为各种法庭案件中的笔迹专家证人。他是该领域发现假签名的首选。
At the risk of sounding egotistical, everybody in the business who wants an opinion on pretty much any presidential person, the first person they come to is me. That's a big change in the 13 years.
冒着听起来自负的风险，在这个行业里，任何想要对几乎任何总统级别的人物发表意见的人，他们找的第一个人就是我。这在过去13年里是一个巨大的变化。
13 years ago. That's when John's career all but collapsed in a scandal so deep and far-reaching that people are still arguing about what exactly happened. Even John himself isn't entirely sure. He made mistakes he didn't know he could make. Mistakes he didn't even suspect. And for years, he didn't talk about it, until now.
13年前。那是约翰的职业生涯几乎在丑闻中崩溃的时候，这个丑闻如此深远，以至于人们至今仍在争论到底发生了什么。即使是约翰本人也不完全确定。他犯了自己不知道会犯的错误。甚至连他自己都没怀疑过的错误。多年来，他一直没提过这件事，直到现在。
It all started in 1992, when John got a call from a guy named Lawrence X. Cusack III.
这一切始于1992年，当时约翰接到了一个叫劳伦斯·X·库萨克三世（Lawrence X. Cusack III）的人的电话。
Very nice, very friendly guy, and he had some beautiful stamps that he was selling that were his father's, his father's collection. And I remember it included some very nice illustrated envelopes from the 19th century. And I bought them in several batches and became very friendly with him. He seemed to be very educated, extremely well polished, very well dressed.
非常好，非常友好的人，他卖一些漂亮的邮票，是他父亲的收藏。我记得其中包含一些来自19世纪的非常漂亮的插画信封。我分几批买了它们，并和他变得非常友好。他看起来受过良好的教育，非常有教养，穿着考究。
The two of them hit it off. They started to hang out on the weekends. John was engaged at the time and Cusack-- everyone called him Lex-- had a pretty young wife. They'd all have dinner at an Italian place. To John, Lex was a kind of worldly older brother. They started confiding in each other.
两人一见如故。他们开始在周末聚会。约翰当时已经订婚，而库萨克——每个人都叫他莱克斯（Lex）——有一个漂亮的年轻妻子。他们都在一家意大利餐厅吃过晚餐。对约翰来说，莱克斯就像一个世故的长兄。他们开始向对方吐露心声。
In the beginning, he unraveled his military career, which I thought was the coolest thing I'd ever heard.
起初，他讲述了自己的军旅生涯，那是我听过最酷的事情。
John had a particular reverence for soldiers. His own dad had served in the Pacific in World War II, and John still talks about the time when he was eight and his father took out his army uniform covered in medals and ribbons, laid it out on the family's ping pong table. Ever since, John had been sort of obsessed with the military. He'd never joined himself, but he was eager to listen to someone like Lex, who told him he'd been in the Navy flying F-16's during Vietnam.
约翰对士兵有一种特别的崇敬。他自己的父亲曾在二战中在太平洋服役，约翰至今仍谈论他八岁时，父亲拿出挂满勋章和丝带的军服，把它铺在家庭乒乓球桌上的情景。从那时起，约翰就有点迷恋军队。他自己从没参过军，但他渴望倾听像莱克斯这样的人说话，他告诉他自己在越南期间曾在海军驾驶F-16战斗机。
Lex was quiet about it. John had to pry the details out of him. That he'd been downed in Cambodia and survived by hiding in a swamp, breathing through a reed. What really struck John, what blew him away, was when they visited the naval academy in Annapolis. Lex's sister-in-law had been admitted, so they went down for plebe weekend.
莱克斯对此很低调。约翰得从他嘴里套出细节。他曾被击落进柬埔寨，躲在沼泽里靠芦苇呼吸才得以生存。真正让约翰震惊，让他目瞪口呆的，是当他们参观安纳波利斯海军学院时。莱克斯的弟媳被录取了，所以他们去参加了新生周末。
You know, a very proud group of friends and family. And when Lex came out he was in a completely white uniform, lieutenant commander's uniform because he was a lieutenant commander, wearing the hat, wearing the Navy cross, wearing all the medals on his chest. And there's 3,000 people there and they're all saluting him. And he's giving back-- if you can imagine my hand going to my head-- a perfect salute. And I'm like, wow. I'm with a war hero here right now, and this is my buddy.
你知道，一群非常自豪的朋友和家人。当莱克斯出来时，他穿着一身洁白的海军中校制服，因为他是一位海军中校，戴着帽子，戴着海军十字勋章，胸前挂着所有的勋章。那里有3000人，他们都在向他敬礼。他回敬——如果你能想象我的手放到头部的动作——一个完美的军礼。我当时想，哇。我正和一个战争英雄在一起，这是我的好友。
A few months after they met, Lex got to talking about his father, also named Lawrence Cusack, who died in 1985. Cusack Senior had been a distinguished lawyer. He'd worked for the Roman Catholic Archdiocese of New York for many years, and he was personal counsel to John Cardinal O'Connor, the archbishop. As Lex explained it, he had some pretty high-powered clients.
他们见面几个月后，莱克斯开始谈论他的父亲，也叫劳伦斯·库萨克，1985年去世。库萨克老先生是一位杰出的律师。他多年来一直为纽约天主教大教区工作，并且是约翰·奥康纳主教的私人法律顾问。正如莱克斯解释的那样，他有一些非常有权势的客户。
At one point, Lex revealed to me that his dad had worked for the Kennedys. And any time I meet somebody who has any connection with anybody famous, I'm like, where are the papers? You know, the papers are valuable. Anything he signed would be valuable. And a conversation ensued on that. And he said he'd look.
有一次，莱克斯向我透露他父亲为肯尼迪家族工作过。任何时候我遇到任何与名人有联系的人，我都会想，文件在哪里？你知道，文件很值钱。他签名的任何东西都会很值钱。于是对话便开始了。他说他会找找看。
A month or so later, Lex mentioned something else interesting.
一个月左右后，莱克斯提到了另一件有趣的事情。
Well then, Marilyn Monroe gets introduced into the equation. My father also worked for Marilyn Monroe. And--
好吧，然后玛丽莲·梦露被引入了方程中。我父亲也为玛丽莲·梦露工作过。而且——
Wait, can you just describe how that all goes down?
等等，你能描述一下那是怎么发生的吗？
Well, Marilyn Monroe had a New York residence, too, and he said he did some legal work for her. And indicated that there was a relationship that his father helped to hush.
嗯，玛丽莲·梦露在纽约也有一个住所，他说他为她做了一些法律工作。并暗示他父亲帮忙掩盖了一段关系。
When he tells you this, what's your reaction? That's pretty crazy news, right?
当他告诉你这些时，你的反应是什么？那可是非常疯狂的消息，对吧？
Yeah. Naturally-- and I think anybody would have this reaction-- you know, the dollar signs are coming in my eyes. I'm thinking, oh my God. This is a career maker for me. This is the treasure that I've been searching for my whole life.
是的。自然地——我想任何人都会有这种反应——你知道，我的眼里出现了美元符号。我在想，噢天哪。这是我职业生涯的转折点。这就是我一生都在寻找的宝藏。
And now are you starting to kind of tell him, like, can I see these papers?
现在你开始告诉他，比如，我可以看这些文件吗？
I'm pushing him. I'm saying, go. Go look for them. Where are they? You know, go get them. Go through the files. You don't know what you might be sitting on. You might be sitting on fortunes. Maybe it's hundreds of thousands, maybe it's millions.
我在催他。我说，去。去看看它们。它们在哪儿？你知道，去拿过来。去翻翻档案。你不知道你可能坐在什么上面。你可能坐在财富上。也许是几十万，也许是几百万。
JFK and Marilyn Monroe-- this was arguably the most storied love affair and cover up of the 20th century. We've all heard the rumors about it for 50 years. But it's just that-- rumors. No one ever had any hard and fast proof, until-- maybe-- now. He forced himself to be patient as Lex searched through his father's extensive and mysterious files. John can't quite remember how long he waited. Maybe weeks or even months, until one day Lex finally shows up at his office with a discovery in hand.
肯尼迪和玛丽莲·梦露——这可以说是有史以来最富传奇色彩、掩盖得最深的情事。50年来，我们都听过关于它的传闻。但仅此而已——传闻。从来没有人有过确凿的证据，直到——也许——现在。他强迫自己耐心等待莱克斯翻阅他父亲庞大而神秘的档案。约翰记不清他等了多久。也许是几周甚至几个月，直到有一天，莱克斯终于带着一个发现出现在他的办公室。
He brought in a briefcase into the office, and I remember there was a document that I believe was on a sheet of stationery that was written in Kennedy's hand. And it sure looked like Kennedy to me. And it basically was written to Marilyn Monroe, and indicated some kind of payoff. He agreed to pay something, or give her something, or set up a trust, I think it was.
他带了一个公文包进办公室，我记得有一份文件我相信是在肯尼迪手写的信纸上写的。它看起来确实像肯尼迪的笔迹。基本上是写给玛丽莲·梦露的，暗示某种赔付。他同意支付什么，或者给她什么，或者建立一个信托，我想是这样的。
In other words, jackpot.
换句话说，大奖。
"Agreement made this third day of March, 1960, between John F. Kennedy, residing at the Carlyle Hotel, New York, New York, and Marilyn Monroe, residing at 444 East 57th Street, New York, New York. Witnesseth, whereas a result of a relationship between Marilyn Monroe, herein referred to as MM, and John F. Kennedy, herein referred to as JFK. MM believes she has suffered irreparable harm to her well being and to her professional life and career. And that such has been the cause of personal hardship and suffering, which is not possible to measure. MM shall never discuss nor reveal to any persons the specifics of the said relationship between her and JFK."
“1960年3月3日达成协议，约翰·肯尼迪（现居住于纽约州纽约市卡莱尔酒店）与玛丽莲·梦露（现居住于纽约州纽约市东57街444号）。见证，由于玛丽莲·梦露（文中称为MM）与约翰·肯尼迪（文中称为JFK）之间的关系，MM认为她的身心健康和职业生活与事业遭受了不可挽回的伤害。这导致了无法衡量的个人困难和痛苦。MM应永远不要讨论或向任何人透露她与JFK之间上述关系的细节。”
And there were other documents like this one. Lex kept finding them. Letters on Kennedy's US Senate stationary, on White House stationary. There were index cards and personal notes. The documents prove JFK's relationship not just with Marilyn Monroe, but with other, sketchier characters as well.
还有其他像这样的文件。莱克斯不断发现它们。肯尼迪美国参议院信纸上的信件，白宫信纸上的信件。还有索引卡和个人笔记。这些文件不仅证明了肯尼迪与玛丽莲·梦露的关系，还证明了他与其他更可疑的人物的关系。
This is a memorandum. And shall I read some of it?
这是一份备忘录。我读一下其中的一些内容？
Yeah.
好的。
"Monroe will refrain from discussing her knowledge of any meetings or discussions of any kind which may have taken place at which were present JFK and Giancana."
“梦露将克制讨论她所知道的任何可能发生的会议或讨论，肯尼迪和吉安卡纳（Giancana）出席了这些会议或讨论。”
Who's Giancana?
吉安卡纳是谁？
Sam Giancana.
山姆·吉安卡纳（Sam Giancana）。
That the mob boss?
那是黑帮老大？
Yes.
是的。
I mean, are you nervous holding these things in your hand for the first time when you're doing it?
我的意思是，当你第一次握着这些东西时，你紧张吗？
I'm nervous on a number of levels. I was scared. I'm thinking that this is really dangerous stuff. How do I handle this? Is this too big for me? How am I going to do this? How am I going to do it right? And also, what's going through my head is, oh my God. Here it is. The Holy Grail. Oh my God, this is worth a lot of money.
我在多个层面上感到紧张。我很害怕。我在想这真是危险的东西。我该怎么处理这个？这对我来说太大了吗？我该怎么做？我该怎么正确地做？而且我脑子里还在想，噢天哪。它在这儿。圣杯。噢天哪，这值很多钱。
In all, Lex unearthed more than 300 documents, a whole archive. And John, of course, considered that maybe, like the Holy Grail, it was too good to be true. So he set about authenticating the papers. He went to at least half a dozen experts in the field, not just handwriting experts, but people who specialize in Kennedy documents. But John didn't want the contents of the papers to get out. He wanted to protect their value, so he sent the experts only a few documents each. Or sometimes portions of documents he'd Xeroxed, excluding the juicy parts.
总共，莱克斯挖掘了300多份文件，整个档案。约翰当然考虑过，也许就像圣杯一样，它太好了，不可能是真的。所以他开始鉴定这些文件。他找了至少六位该领域的专家，不仅是笔迹专家，还有专门研究肯尼迪文件的专家。但约翰不想让这些文件的内容泄露出去。他想保护它们的价值，所以他只给每位专家几份文件。或者有时是复印件，排除了劲爆的部分。
And each one, one by one, authenticated them and said they were real.
每一个人，一个接一个地鉴定它们并说它们是真的。
One of these experts was John's mentor and a giant in the field, Charles Hamilton.
这些专家之一是约翰的导师和该领域的泰斗，查尔斯·汉密尔顿（Charles Hamilton）。
And right away he looked at it. If you look at that book right there where it says The Robot. OK, that's all about John Kennedy's handwriting. So here's the guy that wrote the book. And he looked at it, maybe spent 10 minutes with it. This is authentic. And wrote a letter on it. And that gave me tremendous confidence. It's an important moment for me. It's everyday business for him, because he doesn't know, really, what this signifies.
他立刻看了看。如果你看看那本书，上面写着《机器人》（The Robot）。好吧，那全是关于肯尼迪笔迹的内容。所以写那本书的人就是他。他看了看，可能花了10分钟。这是真实的。并为此写了一封信。这给了我巨大的信心。对我来说这是一个重要的时刻。对他来说这是日常工作，因为他真的不知道这意味着什么。
He has no idea, then, that he's signing off on the fact that JFK gave hush money to Marilyn Monroe, that there was ties to the mob, that he has just kind of, in effect, put his stamp of approval that this is a bona fide chapter in American history?
那么他当时不知道他是在签署证明：肯尼迪给了玛丽莲·梦露封口费，肯尼迪与黑帮有联系，他实际上是在用自己的名义认可这是一个真正的美国历史篇章？
His imprimatur on it meant that everything-- because everything was from the same archive and existed from the same barrel of apples-- was authentic.
他盖的印章意味着一切——因为一切都来自同一个档案，存在于同一桶苹果中——都是真实的。
John, isn't it possible that if you had come to him and said, look, this stuff that I'm giving you here is red hot. This confirms some stuff that people don't want to believe, and some of it is kind of incredible, that he might have said, all right, let me break out the magnifying glass and take a little bit of a closer look here. This is huge what I'm about to do.
约翰，如果你去找他说，看，我给你的这些东西是重磅炸弹。这证实了一些人们不愿相信的事情，其中一些简直不可思议，难道他不会说，好吧，让我拿出放大镜仔细看看吗？我即将做的这件事太大了。
You know, that I won't concede, because I think in knowing how a handwriting expert looks at things, either it is or it isn't. So either it was his handwriting or it wasn't. What it said wasn't important.
你知道，我不会承认这一点，因为我认为在了解笔迹专家看问题的方式后，要么是他的笔迹，要么不是。它说了什么并不重要。
So the papers were authenticated and John laid the groundwork to sell them. He enlisted another dealer of historical papers and artifacts, a well-connected guy named Tom Cloud, to handle the actual sales. Lex would get most of the money. Tom and John would make up to 20%, which they would split evenly.
所以文件被鉴定过了，约翰为出售它们奠定了基础。他招募了另一位历史文件和文物交易商，一个叫汤姆·克劳德（Tom Cloud）的人脉广泛的家伙来处理实际销售。莱克斯会得到大部分钱。汤姆和约翰会得到20%，他们会平分。
They came up with a strategy. They quietly sell the documents to Tom Cloud's roster of wealthy clients on the condition that they not disclose what they'd bought to anyone for a few years. Meanwhile, John and Tom would find someone to write a book about the archive, which would then lead to a movie deal. Once the book and movie were released, of course the value of the documents would likely skyrocket and investors would be happy.
他们想出了一个策略。他们悄悄地把文件卖给汤姆·克劳德名单上的富有客户，条件是他们几年内不对任何人透露他们买了什么。与此同时，约翰和汤姆会找人写一本关于这些档案的书，这将带动电影交易。一旦书和电影发行，文件的价值很可能会飙升，投资者会很高兴。
Everything started to fall into place. An acquaintance connected them with the perfect writer to publicize Lex's archive, Seymour Hersh, the famous investigative journalist who had won a Pulitzer for breaking the My Lai massacre story. Hersh, as it turns out, was already under contract to write a book about JFK's presidency called The Dark Side of Camelot . Cusack began sending copies of the documents in batches, and Hersh started checking that the names and other details in the documents were consistent with his own research.
一切开始就位。一个熟人把他们与最完美的作家联系起来，来宣传莱克斯的档案，那就是西摩·赫什（Seymour Hersh），那位因打破美莱大屠杀故事而获得普利策奖的著名调查记者。赫什实际上已经签订了合同，要写一本关于肯尼迪总统的书，名叫《卡米洛特的阴暗面》（The Dark Side of Camelot）。库萨克开始分批发送文件的副本，赫什开始核实文件中的名字和其他细节是否与他自己的研究一致。
All of a sudden a document would come out and Hersh would independently verify that there was a name of a doctor that injected Kennedy with painkillers for his back, and that nobody knew this. And he found out the name of the doctor through somebody who he had interviewed. And it would be impossible for Lex to have produced that name or these names, like-- or the people who were co-signing the documents, or advisers to Marilyn Monroe that were being verified along the way. There was more confidence. The confidence was building.
突然间，一份文件出来了，赫什会独立核实有一个医生的名字，那个医生为肯尼迪注射止痛药治疗背部，没有人知道这个。他通过他采访过的人发现了那个医生的名字。莱克斯不可能伪造出那个名字，或者这些名字，或者共同签署文件的人，或者是玛丽莲·梦露的顾问，这些都在过程中得到了验证。信心增加了。信心正在建立。
And this was something they could use to build investor confidence, too. Pulitzer Prize-winning author Seymour Hersh is on board and has independently verified key parts of the archive. Hersh's book would come out in November of 1997. In addition, Hersh was working on a documentary about the archive in collaboration with ABC.
这也是他们用来建立投资者信心的方法。普利策奖获得者西摩·赫什加入了，并独立核实了档案的关键部分。赫什的书将于1997年11月出版。此外，赫什正在与ABC合作拍摄一部关于档案的纪录片。
By the end of the summer of 1997, about 140 different investors had made purchases from Tom Cloud. The trust agreement between Kennedy and Monroe had alone sold for $450,000. At this point, the documents had already netted roughly $5 million. It was all going great. They were making a lot of money. John and his fiance got married. Lex's wife was a bridesmaid. And John had a baby boy. Then, one day, John's in Cape Cod and he gets a phone call.
到1997年夏末，大约140个不同的投资者从汤姆·克劳德那里进行了购买。仅肯尼迪和梦露之间的信托协议就卖了45万美元。此时，文件已经净赚了约500万美元。一切进展顺利。他们赚了很多钱。约翰和他的未婚妻结婚了。莱克斯的妻子是伴娘。约翰有个小男孩。然后，有一天，约翰在科德角，接到了一个电话。
August 22, 1997, sitting on the beach.
1997年8月22日，坐在海滩上。
What happens then?
然后发生了什么？
I believe that's the day. Now, I could have it wrong. It's either August 22 or August 27. And I'd like to know what that date is so I could say that's the day that changed my life. That's the call I get from Cloud about Lex being sandbagged by Peter Jennings.
我相信是那天。现在，我可能搞错了。要么是8月22日要么是27日。我想知道那个日期，这样我就能说那是改变我生活的一天。我从克劳德那里接到电话，关于莱克斯被彼得·詹宁斯（Peter Jennings）埋伏了。
Cloud is Tom Cloud, Lex and John's business partner. ABC's Peter Jennings had interviewed for Lex for a segment that would air on 20/20.
克劳德是汤姆·克劳德，莱克斯和约翰的商业伙伴。ABC的彼得·詹宁斯采访了莱克斯，节目将在《20/20》上播出。
Where did the collection come from? The answer lies with Mr. Lex Cusack.
收藏品是从哪里来的？答案在于莱克斯·库萨克先生。
John and Lex had been excited about the segment. They saw it as a kind of phase one of their media launch.
约翰和莱克斯对这个片段很兴奋。他们认为这是他们媒体发布的第一阶段。
Where you aware at any time before your father died that he'd done any work for the Kennedy family?
你在你父亲去世前知道他为肯尼迪家族工作过吗？
No.
不知道。
What became clear very quickly was this wasn't just a puff piece hyping Hersh's book. It was an investigation. You might have heard something about it. It became huge news. What happened was that ABC had gotten wind of some suspicious inconsistencies in the archive. For starters, one of the letters from Cusack Senior, which was dated 1961, had a zip code in the letterhead. It turns out there were no zip codes in 1961. They weren't announced until 1962.
很快就很清楚这不是为了炒作赫什书的广告。这是一项调查。你可能听过这件事。它成了巨大的新闻。发生的事情是ABC得到了一些关于档案中可疑不一致之处的风声。首先，库萨克老先生的一封信，日期是1961年，抬头上有邮政编码。结果是1961年没有邮政编码。直到1962年才宣布。
So ABC hired an expert of its own, a former documents examiner for the FBI. He did forensic analysis of the documents, scrutinizing the paper, the ink, the type. The examiner found that the typeface turned out to be something called Prestige Pica Selectric, which didn't exist until the early 1970s. And whoever typed these documents had also make corrections using a particular kind of lift-off correction tape.
所以ABC聘请了他们自己的专家，一名前FBI文件审查员。他对文件进行了法医分析，仔细检查了纸张、墨水、字体。审查员发现字体原来是一种叫Prestige Pica Selectric的东西，直到1970年代初才存在。而且打出这些文件的打字员也使用了一种特殊的揭除式修正带做了修改。
And lift off tape was not invented or placed onto the market until 1973, a full 10 years after President Kennedy was killed.
而揭除带直到1973年才发明或投放市场，整整比肯尼迪总统遇刺晚了10年。
So this is a blatant forgery by any standard?
所以这是彻头彻尾的伪造，按任何标准来说？
Blatant forgery.
彻头彻尾的伪造。
Jennings takes all this evidence and calmly and methodically presents it to Lex. Lex appears stunned, almost as if he can't process what Jennings is saying.
詹宁斯带着所有证据，冷静而有条不紊地展示给莱克斯看。莱克斯看起来惊呆了，好像无法处理詹宁斯在说什么。
How do you explain that?
你怎么解释那个？
I really don't know. I don't know. This is a problem we grapple with often, is that are these the original documents? Are these copies that were made of the documents? Are these--
我真的不知道。我不知道。这是我们经常面临的问题，这些是原始文件吗？这些是文件的复印件吗？这些是——
Throughout the remainder of our interview, Mr. Cusack offered various explanations for the problems we showed him. But the one that he repeated most often was that the documents we had questioned might be later copies of originals. What he meant by this was never clear.
在采访的剩余部分，库萨克先生对他展示给他的问题提供了各种解释。但他重复最多的解释是，我们质疑的文件可能是原始文件的后制副本。他的意思从不明确。
So somebody might have put their signatures on those documents at a later time.
所以有人可能在之后把签名签在那些文件上。
I'm not talking about the signatures. I'm not talking about the handwriting.
我说的不是签名。我说的不是笔迹。
The documents themselves. I understand what you're saying.
文件本身。我明白你在说什么。
We're talking about the typewriter technology. It was not available at the time these documents were allegedly drawn.
我们在说打字技术。在据称起草这些文件时，它还没出现。
There must be an explanation of why those documents exist, if in fact, they were produced later.
如果那些文件是后来制作的，肯定有它们存在的原因。
Mr. Cusack, somebody has forged the documents.
库萨克先生，有人伪造了这些文件。
I think quite a lot of the other experts will not agree.
我想很多其他专家不会同意。
I'm bound to ask you, Mr. Cusack. Did you forge these documents?
我不得不问你，库萨克先生。是你伪造了这些文件吗？
No sir, I did not.
没有，先生，我没有。
By this time in the interview, there's a pregnant bead of sweat sliding its way down Lex's cheek. He looks desperate and trapped. If the camera panned out, you would half expect to see him manacled to the chair. So this is what Tom Cloud tells John when he calls him on that day in August.
在采访的这个阶段，莱克斯脸颊上滑下一颗饱满的汗珠。他看起来绝望而困住。如果摄影机拉开，你几乎会期待看到他被铐在椅子上。这就是汤姆·克劳德在8月那天打电话给约翰时告诉他的内容。
My heart dropped out of its spot in my body at that point, and it was, oh no.
我的心当时从身体里掉出来了，是啊，噢不。
Here's the interesting thing. It's not, oh no, the papers are fake, or oh no, I've been duped by Lex. Its oh no, we've told the truth, and now we're in for it because we've antagonized the Kennedys, the one family in America you do not antagonize. Plus the mob and God knows who else.
有趣的事情是这样的。不是“噢不，文件是假的”，或者“噢不，我被莱克斯骗了”。而是“噢不，我们说了真话，现在我们要倒霉了，因为我们触怒了肯尼迪家族，这是美国唯一一个你不能触怒的家族。”再加上黑帮和天知道谁。
This must be this very powerful family trying to prevent this information from coming out. And that there's no way that these are fake. That these are real. You know, Lex is a war hero. He's an honest and good man. This can't be. And this is a big conspiracy, and we need to get to the bottom of it.
这一定是非常强大的家族试图阻止这些信息泄露。这些东西绝不可能有假。它们是真的。你知道，莱克斯是战争英雄。他是一个诚实和好的人。这不可能。这是一个巨大的阴谋，我们需要搞清楚真相。
The notion of a conspiracy might sound a bit far-fetched and frightening, but it also offered some assurances. At least in this scenario, the world as John knew it remained constant. The papers were still real. The choices he had made were the right ones. And Lex Cusack was still his dear and trusted friend.
阴谋的概念听起来可能有点牵强且可怕，但它也提供了一些保证。至少在这种情境下，约翰所知的世界保持不变。文件仍然是真的。他所做的选择是正确的。莱克斯·库萨克仍然是他亲爱的、值得信赖的朋友。
That's what I'm thinking. And what seems like minutes afterwards, it's a grand jury investigation.
我当时就是这么想的。几分钟后，大陪审团开始了调查。
John hired a criminal defense lawyer and the two of them made a trip down to the US District Attorney's office in Manhattan. They met with the prosecutor, Paul Engelmayer. And even here, John didn't feel safe.
约翰雇了一名刑事辩护律师，两人去了曼哈顿的美国地方检察官办公室。他们见了检察官保罗·恩格尔迈尔（Paul Engelmayer）。即使在这里，约翰也觉得不安全。
We went in. We went for the proffer session. I told my side of the story. I remember walking into Engelmayer's office, and on his wall was a picture of Kennedy on the beach in Hyannis. And that just in my mind was, oh my God. This is a set up. I'm going down because I've revealed the biggest secret of the last 40 years, and they don't want this secret to come out. So somehow they're going to make it look like I'm a bad guy. He's working for them. This is all a conspiracy. All these bells are going off in my head.
我们进去了。我们参加了陈述会议。我讲了我的版本。我记得走进恩格尔迈尔的办公室，墙上挂着一张肯尼迪在海恩尼斯海滩的照片。我脑子里只想到，噢天哪。这是一个陷阱。我要倒霉了，因为我揭露了过去40年最大的秘密，他们不希望这个秘密泄露。所以他们想方设法让我看起来是个坏人。他为他们工作。这一切都是阴谋。我脑子里所有的警钟都在响。
During this period, things got pretty dark for John. He began taking medication to reduce his anxiety and to prevent panic attacks. Still, he was paranoid. He became convinced that something terrible would happen to him, that his car would blow up when he turned the key.
在这段时间里，约翰的日子变得很黑暗。他开始服用药物来减轻焦虑和预防恐慌发作。尽管如此，他还是多疑。他变得确信会发生可怕的事情，比如他转动钥匙时车会爆炸。
I'm thinking that somebody's going to kill me, basically. That's what's going to happen. That this stuff was not supposed to be released, and there's going to be an accident.
我在想基本上有人要杀了我。这就是要发生的事。这些东西本来不应该被公开，会发生一场事故。
And all this time, John is rehashing the Peter Jennings interview and the inconsistencies with the documents. The typeface and the zip code, the lift-off correction tape. What explained all that? The first chance he got he confronted Lex.
所有这些时间里，约翰都在重温彼得·詹宁斯的采访和文件中的不一致之处。字体、邮政编码、揭除修正带。这能解释这一切吗？他一有机会就去质问莱克斯。
We met somewhere, I don't remember where. And he was holding his hands to his head. He didn't know what to do. He'll just give all the money back. Of course, he had spent most of the money then.
我们在某处见了面，我不记得在哪里。他双手抱着头。他不知道该怎么办。他想把钱全还回去。当然，他那时已经花了大部分钱。
Where did these come from if they're not real? How could they be?
如果它们不是真的，这些是从哪儿来的？怎么可能？
"I did it," he said. "I did it. It just got carried away."
“我干的，”他说。“是我干的。太失控了。”
He's confessing to you, I forged these documents?
他向你坦白，我伪造了这些文件？
He didn't say exactly that. He said, "I did it. I'm the one who did it."
他没确切说那句。他说，“是我干的。我是那个干这件事的人。”
And I said, "What are you talking about? How could this be? How could this possibly be? What are you telling me?" And then he recanted. He said, "I just said that because it was a moment. I didn't really do it. I don't know what this could be. Maybe it's a conspiracy." I don't know what he was saying. I don't remember, but he was equivocating.
我说，“你在说什么？怎么可能？怎么会这样？你在告诉我什么？”然后他撤回了。他说，“我只是在那一刻随口说的。我没真干。我不知道这是怎么回事。也许是一个阴谋。”我不知道他在说什么。我不记得了，但他当时在模棱两可。
What especially bothered John was something else completely. During the 20/20 segment, Peter Jennings had reported that ABC could find no evidence that Lex was a retired naval officer.
尤其困扰约翰的是另一件完全不同的事情。在《20/20》节目期间，彼得·詹宁斯报道说，ABC找不到任何证据证明莱克斯是一名退役海军军官。
I mean, that was a big thing for me, the military thing. If he was this military hero, in my mind, these can't possibly be non-authentic.
我的意思是，那对我来说是一件大事，军队的事情。如果他是这个军事英雄，在我看来，这些东西不可能不是真实的。
When you confront him with this, what does he say?
当你用这个质问他时，他说了什么？
On one hand he says, well, it was just kind of a story that got carried away. On the other hand, he said, well, there are things that I can't talk about. Like the indication to me was, OK, he was MI5 or that it really was real, but he was some kind of covert agent and he couldn't talk about it. It seemed believable.
一方面他说，嗯，这只是一个失控的故事。另一方面，他说，嗯，有些事情我不能说。比如给我的暗示是，好吧，他是MI5或者它是真的，但他是一个秘密特工，他不能说。这看起来很可信。
Before you scream to yourself, how could he so stupid, consider that John's realization about Lex meant dismantling everything he understood about himself. John's entire career was based on knowing the real thing when he saw it. He could judge the authenticity of stamps, and signatures, and documents, and, most importantly, people. Especially friends. In other words, John was no dupe. No way. And not only was there a lot of money on the table, these documents were going to make his career. So while it might sound crazy that he'd believe that Lex was MI5, it made even less sense that John himself was a sucker.
在你尖叫之前，他怎么能这么蠢，考虑一下约翰对莱克斯的认识意味着解构他对自己理解的一切。约翰的整个职业生涯都是基于在看到真实物品时能认出来。他能判断邮票、签名、文件的真实性，最重要的是，人的真实性。尤其是朋友。换句话说，约翰不是傻瓜。绝不是。而且不仅桌上有大笔钱，这些文件还会成就他的职业生涯。所以虽然他会相信莱克斯是MI5听起来很疯狂，但约翰自己是个傻瓜更说不通。
I would hang on anything that would be a thread that would be, yes, see, I was right. Here's the record of him being a covert agent for the CIA in military clothing, or whatever would happen that would make this whole thing, the whole nightmare, end.
我会抓住任何一条线索，即，是的，你看，我是对的。这是他身穿军装为CIA当秘密特工的记录，或者任何会发生的事情让这一切、整个噩梦结束。
John's lawyer told him that he had to clear his name, and the only way to do that was to secretly record Lex. He needed to get him on tape discussing their earlier conversation where Lex confessed and then recanted. Because that would show the prosecutor that John was innocent. After all, Lex wouldn't be confessing and making excuses if John were in on the scam.
约翰的律师告诉他，他必须洗清自己的名字，唯一的方法就是秘密录下莱克斯的话。他需要让他谈论他们之前的谈话，在那次谈话中莱克斯承认了然后又撤回了。因为那会向检察官证明约翰是无辜的。毕竟，如果约翰参与了骗局，莱克斯就不会承认错误并找借口。
John at first refused, arguing that Lex hadn't done anything wrong. His lawyer insisted. And he said, well, you don't have to do it if you don't want to. But tomorrow, if you don't do it, it's fine, but you need to get a new lawyer.
约翰起初拒绝了，声称莱克斯没做错任何事。律师坚持。他说，好吧，如果你不想你可以不做。但明天，如果你不做，没关系，但你需要找个新律师。
I can't help but think that you know something. I can't help it. I'm sorry.
我忍不住觉得你知道些什么。我忍不住。我很抱歉。
So John did it. His lawyer hired a private detective to wire John's office with a hidden microphone. He and Lex talked for an hour. They're both tense and emotional. Lex leaps from topic to topic, offering one wild, half-baked explanation after another, while John tries to pin him down.
所以约翰照做了。他的律师聘请了一名私家侦探给约翰的办公室装上了隐形麦克风。他和莱克斯谈了一个小时。他们都很紧张和情绪化。莱克斯从一个话题跳到另一个话题，提供一个又一个疯狂、半生不熟的解释，而约翰试图让他定下来。
The thing that I can't get out of my mind, what's bothering me that I can't get out of my mind is when you came here-- what was it-- three days after. OK, you're sitting there, and you're telling me that you're guilty, that you did everything, that everything's fake. You've got to listen.
我脑子里挥之不去的事情，困扰我挥之不去的事情是当你来到这里——那是什么——三天之后。好吧，你坐在那儿，你告诉我你有罪，你做了所有事，所有东西都是假的。你必须听着。
I'm listening to you. I am. I'm listening to you.
我在听你说话。我是。我在听你说话。
Lex, I'm telling you, I'm looking at my son's picture.
莱克斯，我告诉你，我正在看我儿子的照片。
I know. John, I know. I'm looking at your son's picture. I'm looking at you. You don't realize how close I feel to you. So I'm looking at you and I'm going oh my God. I've ruined this guy's life.
我知道。约翰，我知道。我在看你儿子的照片。我在看你。你不知道我感觉和你有多亲近。所以我看着你，我想噢天哪。我毁了这个人的生活。
Well, that's true.
嗯，那是真的。
OK, so I'm going oh my God.
好吧，所以我说噢天哪。
Lex tells John he only confessed in order to protect his father's reputation. He didn't want anyone thinking his father had forged the documents, or that his father was somehow connected to the mob. Though, maybe his father did fake some papers for whatever reason.
莱克斯告诉约翰他承认错误只是为了保护他父亲的名声。他不想让人认为他父亲伪造了这些文件，或者他父亲以某种方式与黑帮有关。虽然，也许他父亲确实为了某种原因伪造了一些文件。
I'm thinking like, people are going to think my father's a mob lawyer. My brother's going to think he was a mob lawyer and that he forged this stuff to protect himself from getting in trouble. And now it's all like, I can't let that happen. So it's more like what if we just say, we'll give everything back and the whole thing will go away. We'll just pay everybody back, it was a big mistake, we don't know what caused it.
我想人们会认为我父亲是黑帮律师。我哥哥会认为他是黑帮律师，他伪造这些东西是为了保护自己免受麻烦。现在看起来，我不能让这种情况发生。所以更像是如果我们只是说，我们会把所有东西还回去，整件事就会消失。我们会把钱还给每个人，这只是一个大错误，我们不知道原因。
It was like I was having a nervous breakdown practically. I couldn't figure out what the hell-- it was such a shock. What could possibly have happened? Could my dad have done this? If he did do it, [UNINTELLIGIBLE PHRASE].
这感觉就像我几乎神经崩溃了。我搞不清楚究竟怎么回事——这简直是震惊。究竟发生了什么？我父亲干的吗？如果他干了[难以听清]。
Lex seems generally confused. The only thing Les essentially admits lying about is his navy career. He tells John it was more or less a joke that got out of hand until a number of people, including Lex's own wife, were under the impression that he'd actually fought in Vietnam. The thing barely hangs together.
莱克斯看起来非常困惑。莱克斯本质上唯一承认撒谎的是他的海军生涯。他告诉约翰，那或多或少是一个失控的玩笑，直到包括莱克斯自己的妻子在内的许多人都认为他真的参加了越南战争。这件事几乎站不住脚。
As for the crisp, white lieutenant commander's uniform that John had seen him wearing that day in Annapolis--
至于约翰那天在安纳波利斯看到的他穿着的洁白海军中校制服——
Where'd you get the uniform?
你在哪儿弄到的制服？
[UNINTELLIGIBLE PHRASE].
[难以听清]。
That gives you a military uniform with your name on it and everything?
那给你提供了一套有你名字等信息的军服？
I didn't have my name on it. It had a name tag.
我上面没名字。它有一个铭牌。
And the Navy cross?
那海军十字勋章呢？
Lex didn't want to comment for this story. So all I have to go on from him is the TV footage and the wire recording. There, Lex mostly comes across as pathetic. He doesn't show any of the smooth cunning of the Hollywood con man. Instead, his genius-- if that's what it is-- is his lack of finesse. If he's conning John, and his disguise is the pitiable friend who got in over his head, then he plays it very, very well. So well that after the secretly recorded meeting, John says he didn't feel relieved or justified. He felt awful.
莱克斯不想对这个故事发表评论。所以我唯一能掌握的资料就是电视片段和录音。在那里，莱克斯大多表现得可怜。他没有好莱坞骗子的圆滑狡猾。相反，他的天才——如果那是的话——是他的缺乏技巧。如果他在骗约翰，而他的伪装是一个陷入困境的可怜朋友，那么他演得非常好、非常完美。以至于在秘密录音会议后，约翰说他没有感到解脱或正义。他感觉糟糕透了。
There was an Irish pub on the street over from my office, and I remember drinking three Guinesses in like 10 minutes. And I'm not a drinker. I was like, wow. What did I just do?
我办公室对面有一家爱尔兰酒吧，我记得在10分钟内喝了三杯吉尼斯啤酒。我不是那种会喝酒的人。我当时想，哇。我刚做了什么？
Is there a part of you still believing this guy could be a decorated navy officer who has the real documents, and I'm betraying him?
你心里还有一部分认为这家伙可能是个获得勋章的海军军官，他有真实文件，而我在背叛他吗？
I think there's still, like-- I don't know why, but like a 1/100 of 1% part of me that still thinks that.
我想可能还有，就像——我不知道为什么，但我想我心里还有百分之一的百分之一认为那是真的。
John says the real aha moment for him finally came with an FBI agent told him point blank that Lex had never served in the military. In other words, Lex's best move, whether by luck or design, was that he hit John's Achilles' heel. He passed himself off as a decorated soldier. So Lex's deepest betrayal wasn't the JFK papers. It was claiming he breathed through a reed in Cambodia.
约翰说他真正的恍然大悟时刻最终来自一名FBI特工直截了当地告诉他，莱克斯从没在军队服役。换句话说，莱克斯最高明的动作，无论是因为运气还是设计，是他击中了约翰的阿喀琉斯之踵。他把自己伪装成一名受勋士兵。所以莱克斯最深的背叛不是肯尼迪文件。而是声称他在柬埔寨靠芦苇呼吸。
Lex was convicted in federal court of mail and wire fraud and served nearly 10 years in prison. He got out about three years ago. Seymour Hersh's reputation took a temporary hit, especially after he testified at trial that he quote unquote, "misstated things regarding his independent verifications."
莱克斯在联邦法院被判邮件和电信欺诈罪，并在监狱里服刑了近10年。他大约三年前出来的。西摩·赫什的名声受到了暂时的打击，特别是在他出庭作证说他引用并“歪曲了关于他独立验证的事情”之后。
John was cleared of any wrongdoing, but his life didn't just bounce right back. His business suffered. He had to resign as President of the Professional Autograph Dealers Association, an organization he founded. His marriage fell apart. The JFK papers nearly ruined him. And-- it's not surprising-- he's had a hard time trusting people since.
约翰被清除了任何不当行为，但他的生活并没有就此反弹。他的生意受损。他不得不辞去他创立的专业签名交易商协会的主席职务。他的婚姻破裂了。肯尼迪文件差点毁了他。而且——这并不奇怪——从那以后他很难信任别人。
I definitely have trust issues in my life. There's no question that I have trust issues because of this. I mean, you get paranoid. Is Lex my friend because I'm such a great guy, or is it because I was a foil in his plot to take over the world? And then I'm thinking, is this person really my friend who really is my friend, another person in my life? And I do do that, and I feel terrible and guilty about when I'm distrustful and I shouldn't be. But it's there. And I have to temper that all the time.
我的生活中确实有信任问题。毫无疑问，因为这件事我有信任问题。我的意思是，你会变得多疑。莱克斯和我交朋友是因为我人太好了，还是因为我是他统治世界阴谋中的棋子？然后我在想，这个人真的像我朋友一样真的是我朋友吗，我生活中的其他人？我确实会那样做，当我不信任别人而又不应该这样时，我感到非常糟糕和内疚。但它就在那里。我必须一直调整这种心态。
But in a weird way he's thankful too. His paranoia made him better at what he does. It was after the Cusack fiasco that he threw himself into studying fakes and forgeries, and made himself so good at spotting them.
但从某种奇怪的角度看，他也心存感激。他的多疑让他更擅长他所做的事情。就是在库萨克闹剧之后，他才一头扎进赝品和伪造品的研究中，让自己变得如此擅长识别它们。
When I show John a copy of one of the Cusack documents, he started to analyze the handwriting all over again. It was a document from an archive that had fooled so many experts and that some people in the field, even to this day, argue is real. He turned the paper upside down just as his mentor Charles Hamilton taught him to do, so you aren't distracted by the actual letters. You just see the lines, the curves, and the dots.
当我给约翰看库萨克文件中的一份复印件时，他开始再次分析笔迹。这是一份来自档案的文件，曾欺骗了那么多专家，以至于该领域的一些人至今仍争论它是真的。他把纸倒过来，正如他的导师查尔斯·汉密尔顿教他的那样，这样你就不会被实际的字母分散注意力。你只看到线条、曲线和圆点。
Now, the Js were always different, but look at the Jack, for instance, upside down. And just look at the way the spacing, and how it's inconsistent and bouncy. It's very, very good. The forgery is very, very good. I have no idea how they were made. No idea. That, to me, is the big mystery in my life. I don't know how he did it. I don't know how they were so good. I have no idea. Or if he did it. I don't even know that he did it. Maybe somebody else did it and he pushed them forward.
现在，J总是不同的，但看Jack，举个例子，倒过来。只看间距，以及它是如何不一致和跳跃的。这非常好。伪造品非常、非常好。我不知道它们是怎么做出来的。不知道。那对我来说是我一生中最大的谜。我不知道他是怎么做到的。我不知道它们怎么会那么好。我不知道。或者如果是他做的。我甚至不知道是不是他做的。也许别人做的，他推到前面。
How hard is it to pull off what Lex pulled off?
实现莱克斯所做的事情有多难？
I don't think anybody has ever done that in the history of our field as successfully as he did for the amount of time that he did.
我不认为在我们领域的历史上，有人像他在那段时间里那样成功地做到这一点。
And how was he able to do that?
他怎么能做到这一点？
Sheer genius, I'd say. Sheer genius.
纯粹的天才，我会说。纯粹的天才。
And perhaps Lex was a mastermind. But then again, we all want to think we can only be fooled by a genius.
也许莱克斯是个主谋。但话说回来，我们都想认为我们只能被天才愚弄。
Jake Halpern is the author most recently of the book World's End.
杰克·哈珀恩是最近《世界末日》一书的作者。
[MUSIC- "I'M GONNA FILE MY CLAIM" BY MARILYN MONROE]
[音乐 - 玛丽莲·梦露的“I'M GONNA FILE MY CLAIM”]
The song stylings of Marilyn Monroe.
玛丽莲·梦露的演唱风格。
[ACKNOWLEDGEMENTS]
[鸣谢]
This American Life is distributed by Public Radio International. WBEZ management oversight for our show by our boss, Mr. Torey Malatia. In the mailroom this week, I was surprised to catch him opening a love letter he got from some random listener.
《美国生活》由公共广播国际公司发行。我们节目的管理监督是我们的老板托雷·马拉蒂亚先生。本周在收发室，我惊讶地发现他正在拆开一封他从某个随机听众那里收到的情书。
This is not unusual. I can't tell you how many people have come forward over the years. I probably have three or four dozen examples of that.
这并不罕见。我数不清这些年来有多少人站出来。我大概有三四十个这样的例子。
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周回来，带来更多《美国生活》的故事。
PRI. Public Radio International.
PRI。公共广播国际公司。